[Music]
in times of all the world was full of
wonder and magic but times change
mortar mama hey birthday boy by the laws
of your I must dub the a man today kneel
before me that's okay I have a gift from
your dad he said to give you this when
you were both over sixteen no it's a
wizard step dad was a wizard what your
dad was an accountant
this spell brings him back for one all
day dad will be back like like back to
life that's not possible it is with this
I'm gonna meet dad
ah hisses legs I definitely remember dad
having a top part Oh what did I do
hi we only have 24 hours to bring the
rest of him back hey Dad you look just
like I remember
a problem shape
you see you come to the right pattern
[Music]
we might be out of gas but it says we
have a full tank that doesn't work
growth spell we grow the can and then
the gas inside will grow with it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is huge and your five years ago I
thought I lost you forever
there is no curse that could ever tell
me away from you will you marry me yes
[Music]
vicious have a little bit of news don't
ruin my morning
don't ask me to marry him no I wasn't
really asking nor was I love doesn't
always end well beasty trust me
let us prove you wrong you have done an
admirable job going against your own
nature to raise this child but now he
will finally get the love of a real
mother tonight I consider Elora
[Music]
what have you done
Maleficent is a threat to everyone but
you are best at
[Music]
[Applause]
one can never be too careful
[Music]
you
you do not know me
tell me what happened there was another
creature
we've spent years caring for a shoe
now it's time to careful your own it's
time to introduce myself
[Music]
just three ounces of pressure to the
vagus nerve and then look at your boy
sleepy night night Blanche sterling the
legendary spy who's always dressed to
impress
Walter Beckett graduated MIT at 15 and
works in the tech innovations lab there
are so many gadgets I want to test in
the field for example the inflatable
hook kind of a personal protection
device I've been developing this is a
vile waste of taxpayer dollars this is
your next objective none of our agents
can get close to him I have something
that can help it's called biodynamic
concealment imagine if I can make you
disappear hey Lance look at me look at
you I can see my butt and your face at
the same time that is so cool
being a pigeon could make you an even
better spy pigeons are everywhere nobody
notices them Asians can see in slow
motion
that was tight did anyone else see a
pigeon and [ __ ] can fly up to 92
miles per hour don't you throw me
officers he'll figure it out
all right camera starting it's about to
get messy time to go sleepy night-night
I miss my hands I gotta stay you're
squeezing - OH
what happens in a submarine stays in a
submarine far away as north as we can go
once stood an enchanted forest you see
an enchanted forest
yes it was a magical place but something
went wrong since then no one can get in
what would I do without you you'll
always have me
[Music]
how's Elsa seemed weird to you she seems
like Elsa there's this voice voice what
does that mean
the kingdom is not safe find who is
calling to you they may have answers I'm
going with you
Anna no excuse me I climb to the North
Mountain survived two frozen heart and
saved you from my ex-boyfriend so you
know I'm coming thanks normally
where are we
how did you get in the forest then this
party for her has impossible where did
you learn magic
I can't just follow me into fire then
don't run into fire
[Music]
magic is very alluring without you she
may lose herself
protect arendelle a to all cost
[Music]
I believe in you Elsa more than anyone
or anything
[Music]
quick question is the whole putting up
some mortal danger gonna be a regular
thing
[Music]
let me guess you're like the center of
your people's universe right
[Applause]
indeed well I've got no leashes
our fences
with me every day could be an adventure
hi
[Music]
there's something else
today
[Music]
um hello just for you a handsome postman
mr. Klaus you have a gift you were meant
for making toys so I figure it if you
donate your old toys I'll deliver them
for free tonight I go with you there's
no need for you to come with me really
tonight then
you write a letter to mr. Klaus he'll
make its toy here mr. Klaus beer mr.
Klaus shall we then
yep Klaus what about me you're you're
right you're a up yeah sure you're too
far you're gone
hey what do you guys think you're doing
this is smear ins bird for Yun happiest
place on earth and you two can't change
that
the postman and homemaker brainwashing
everyone we need to show people that a
true selfless act always sparks another
hi what's happening right now
oh no what happened you just sit there
be all magical and awesome
yes / we're doing it let's go
oh wait wait wait time out really that's
how you laugh
come on we're running at a time those
kids are counting on us if we don't stop
them tonight this town will never be the
same
destroy those toys
yes no they're not attached
why aren't they attached I thought they
were attached I would never in a million
years have done what I just did if I
didn't think these were attached
[Music]
legend has it there is a tree in the
Amazon that possesses unparalleled
healing powers and the Arrowhead is the
key to unlocking it hello I just wanted
you to know this has been mislabeled
he's shipping outlets
of all the jungle cruisers you can take
in the Amazon
this one is undoubtedly the Chiefs but
also the most thrilling heads up come a
Duke
look out
Marauders
natives ladies and gentlemen the moment
you've all been waiting for
the backside of water stays wonder of
the world we're headed upriver lagrimas
de cristal for mr. Huron travel come on
not a good time my brother and I are
looking for passage upriver please go
away
I have a lot of money ever you believe
in legends do you believe in curses -
you're gonna beg minutes are back well I
look forward to disappointing you 10,000
to bring you there alive dead is 15,000
why should I pay me dead
dad I'd have to carry you that's a lot
harder lady here we go
oh sorry Frank it's alright strong form
I cannot swim you put the river cruising
you can't swim
the price just went out
[Music]
yo snow cone yes my bratty little
reindeer
[Music]
my name is Noelle Kringle Martin confess
my partridge in a pear tree underwear
nice washing oh well then my Christmas
wish has been granted
Christmas runs in my family my dad was
Santa and now it's my brother next turn
to wear the hat stocking full of cold
feathers see one he saved a kitten from
a tree nice brother I'd be ready by
Christmas of course he's a cream
sometimes I dream about getting out well
you can't be Santa if you're having a
nervous breakdown you it'll get away for
the weekend the first time in 2,000
years
Santa has disappeared I just said he
should take the weekend off we must have
a new center Gabriel
Kringle me I'm in the tech department
and loving it what about a rescue
mission do you mind telling me what
you're doing I'm going to get my brother
and you're coming with me
stay right where you are we are looking
for Santa Claus
you don't tell anybody who you are where
are you think I'm in town a front for or
you came from sir it's a privilege to
wear that suit put some pants on so
naughty
Christmas Eve has less than 48 hours
away this could be the perfect time to
start an online delivery platform gotta
find Santa thousands appearance booth
jingle bells and delivered toys and we
must make sure nothing changes that I
like your pants they're jolly they're
yoga pants like yours these are my
yogurt pants and no yoga pants and love
yogurt pants
I want facing reindeer please wow that's
a big deal in here so I tell you a story
it's the story of an orphan girl from a
faraway land he was sent to live a
mysterious house
[Music]
and what if I were to tell you she
discovered something magical
scooping secret
[Music]
would you believe me
[Music]
[Music]
if you cause me trouble I'll have you
sent away in an instant
[Music]
and we were hiding something this garden
it's capable of it stored my fins
now will you believe in the magic
[Music]
our word has never been in more danger
[Music]
human greed is what drove us underground
all those years ago to escape from your
rapacious appetite
because the
I warn you boy
[Music]
you are not prepared for the truth
behind what you seek
[Music]
no you will believe
are you less fair
[Music]
[Music]
gotta go fast
20 minutes ago an energy surge knocked
out power across the entire Pacific
Northwest this needs someone who can
figure out exactly what we're dealing
with
you're not suggest me well I think
you're suggesting we have no choice
what are you in charge here yes I am I'm
wrong
mommy charge allow me to clarify in a
sequentially ranked hierarchy based on
level of critical importance the
disparity between us is too vast to
quantify agent stone the doctor thinks
your basic listen pal I don't know if
you realize I'm sorry I major what was
your name benjoe nobody cares
[Music]
meow basically it looks like I'm gonna
have to save your planet no but thank
you for asking
whatever this creature is our job is to
secure it neutralize it see what makes
it tick
[Music]
look at this I took 9 million steps
today
stay in there to be quiet how much
longer I keep three even here do you
have your child in that Bank no I mean
yes it's a child but it's not mine it's
not your child
smells like bodies bringing an old ham
sandwich
[Music]
[Music]